it has passed sent ten years since you
received the economic price what impact
has it had on your professional and
maybe on your private life for the last
ten years well it's at almost ten years
it has had a tremendous impact on my
life more than on the life of most Prize
winners because I was in an unusual
situation I I was unemployed at the time
and I was in good health I reached the
age of 66 and beginning to get Social
Security but I didn't have much of that
I had many years of unemployment before
me and so uh it I was in a position to
be very much influenced when night the
recognition of my earlier work came
about in this way but I had I become
widely known but in a sense it wasn't
officially recognized I was quoted very
frequently in the literature of
economics and mathematics but it's quite
difficult to get a official recognition
you